el grupo paramilitar Wagner dejará de
existir o cambiará su forma de
funcionamiento durante una entrevista al
periódico local comersant el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin se refirió a la
reunión que sostuvo el pasado 29 de
junio con 35 miembros de alto Rango del
grupo paramilitar aseguró que hicieron
el balance de más de un año en la
invasión a Ucrania y del breve motín
fallido del pasado 24 de junio ante la
pregunta de sivagner mantendrá sus
operaciones Putin respondió
bueno Wagner no existe no tenemos una
ley sobre organizaciones militares
privadas Simplemente no es decir si no
hay ley Entonces no existe el grupo
Wagner no existe tal entidad legal hay
un grupo pero legalmente no existe de
hecho la legalidad del grupo Wagner
nunca ha existido su nombre empezó a ser
conocido en la toma de crimea de 2014 y
en Siria como parte del apoyo ruso al
régimen de bachar a lassat el grupo de
mercenarios también ha estado
involucrado en países africanos como mal
y República centroafricana y Libia Rusia
siempre había negado su apoyo hasta la
invasión a Ucrania a gran escala de 2022
cuando finalmente el kremlin aceptó
abiertamente la financiación del grupo
paramilitar y presumió repetidamente
sobre los avances de Wagner en la guerra
a finales de junio el gobierno ruso dijo
que el grupo de mercenarios mantendría
sus operaciones en África y en la misma
entrevista al periódico comesant El
presidente Putin dijo que propuso al
Mercenario de alto Rango andrey crochef
conocido como sedoy como reemplazo del
ex comandante de Wagner Jeff Jenni
rigogin pero la decisión final de la
continuidad de Wagner o sus cambios
estaría en la cámara baja rusa